hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment of what
you never knew it's that time of year
again Thanksgiving and we're here to
look at the timeless classics that
always pop around this holiday that's
right
all two of them three of you desperate
and seeing how you probably need a break
from a peanut Alawis Nana peanuts
Christmas by God they will consume every
holiday what is wrong with that I'll
take over the world let's take a look at
planes trains and automobiles this is
not only one of the best Thanksgiving
movies to watch every year but it's also
one of the greatest comedies of all time
the writing the acting the anger the joy
the sadness the redemption is just a
little bit of everything and like most
great comedies there's a ton of little
touches that you may not have noticed
we're right in front of you the whole
time and we're here to look at them here
today they're not behind the scenes or
nitpicking plotholes they're just the
kick-ass little moments you never knew
we're making the movie even more tickets
so let's not waste any time
let's take a look at planes trains and
automobiles
you
being a John Hughes production it's no
big shock that the home in this movie is
in Chicago but did it have to be the
exact same house from home alone yeah
look pretty similar don't they a lot of
people speculated that this is the same
house but if you look closely you'll
notice there are some differences
however the house that was used for home
alone it turns out is just a few miles
down the street so even though it's not
the same home you can say for sure that
the page's family and the McCallister's
grew up practically in the same
neighborhood those are the precious
moments too we all know the calling
cards of del Griffith
giant sue K's tons of clutter and of
course shower curtain rings but even
before we knew that there were clues to
his identity before he was introduced
for example when Dell accidentally
steals Neil's cab you'll notice that in
the puddle where the cab used to be
there's what else a shower curtain or a
blink for a second and you might miss it
there's a few other clues to a situation
as well he has this line about work and
family
I got a motto like your work love your
wife I'll remember that
however when they get off the plane Neil
immediately calls his family while Dell
immediately calls a hotel as soon as we
got off the plane you called home I
called the Braidwood in if you're
supposed to like your work and love your
wife why didn't he call his wife you
wonder also if you look closely at the
stickers on the suitcase you'll notice
they're all just for hotels this makes
sense as those are the only places he'd
be able to visit and get memorabilia
from probably better than the mementos
Neil took back from his travels quite
shocked out of the shank if you're gonna
brush your teeth all right cameo time hi
Michael McKean hi boyfriend mrs.
Doubtfire hi lawyer from Jurassic Park I
Ferris Bueller's father and teacher and
principal secretary hi guy from the
plane and home alone you know that
dangly wands guy and of course
hello seemingly pointless Kevin Bacon
appearance yeah this is such a strange
little popin isn't it well many people
wonder why he made such a quick and
voiceless cameo people have questioned
if this could possibly be the same
character from another John Hughes movie
she's having a baby however later in the
film we also see that she's having a
baby is playing on television
see what if it was one of your friends
huh so if this is in the same universe
how are their stories being played on TV
I don't know
bottom line there is definitely a
connection here not necessarily we all
hate watching the edited version of
films on TV right they always censor the
best parts and cut it down for time well
with this movie you get the edits but
you also get something a little extra
it's a deleted scene where Neil's trying
to eat his airplane food and big
surprise a bunch of stuff goes wrong
it's really funny and I'm not sure why
it was cut out of the original you can
see it on the special edition blu-ray or
like I said just catch it on TV if you
have her channel surfing needless to say
this is one of the few times where they
added something instead of just taking
away you know that's a damn rare thing
these days
speaking of censoring back in 1987 this
film would have no problem getting a PG
rating it is literally just one minute a
film that tosses it into the our
category but by god is it worth it you
can start by wiping that fucking dumbass
smile off your rosy fucking cheeks then
you can give me a fucking automobile it
fucking that's a fucking Toyota a
fucking Mustang a fucking Buick it's so
strange because the f-word is not used
anywhere else in the film if people know
they can use it as gun result in an
r-rating then usually they use it
throughout the majority of it but here
it's literally just one scene even the
nudie shots of the women in the taxi
could still get away with a PG rating
back then yeah I know ratings will rear
them not like now where they take an eye
out that somehow gets a PG rating but
Neil's to say if this one moment was
taken out it would have no trouble
allowing most kids into the seats it's
all because of a solid 60 seconds of 18
thoughts being given the fact that it is
just this one scene and that's used so
many times makes the joke all the more
better mmm boy oh boy
what
here's a piece of irony it turns out
that if Neil and Dell just stayed at the
airport they probably would have made it
back just in time yeah it flies by real
fast but there is a scene where his wife
is watching the news and they say that
O'Hare is clearing up traffic is
resuming at O'Hare field and flights
will be moving out of there very shortly
that means that this crazy has
experienced all could have been avoided
if he only waited a touch longer that's
gathered John Candy was one of our
greatest comedians and was always great
at adding little touches in his
performances del Griffith is no
exception like have you ever noticed he
rarely zips up his boots this is
probably because he enjoys letting his
feet out like before oh oh that feels
good also he seems totally okay with
putting cigarettes out in his grapefruit
you're a miracle and just to add insult
to injury on Neal's part everything in
his bag is either a bowel or gas related
product guaranteeing that he's in for a
really bad night there's also
speculation that his snoring is slowly
to the tune of shave and a haircut it
would drive anybody insane for the
comedy is that they're always coming
across strange and usually not very
bright characters for example what's
this guy's story with the mice he just
has a box full of mice out why another
phase when they pull into the office of
this incredibly tacky hotel that has two
signs pointing out that it's an office
what's the point of that why is it
needed also even though Neil's name is
clearly introduced this hotel manager
gets it wrong immediately after hearing
it this is Neal page Neal gosh Mooney
madam agent Nick also notice that after
Ben Stein smiles after delivering bad
news another strange thing to do the
destination is now changed to the word
know where this Airport has a sick sense
of humor would you like a mouthful of
teeth
this is Neil page from Chicago yeah you
ever noticed that even though they crash
into a hotel room and leave without
telling anybody they're still polite
enough to put their turn signal on
I guess fleeing the scene doesn't mean
they have to have bad manners just
strange priorities fans from the movie
airplane will recognize that this is the
exact same shot often used in the film
fitting seeing how both are paramount
productions here's a good idea have a
point it makes it so much more
interesting for the listener one of
humble touches in this film is their
ability to have you literally see Neil
pages thought process in most movies a
character's point of view is represented
through just getting a close-up of an
expression or through dialogue but here
they do it a little more cleverly teens
where Neil imagines Adele as the devil
or imagining himself as a Frey skeleton
or smart but there's some visuals that
require so much effort yet go by so fast
that they're easy to miss like when Neil
recognises Dell from the cab it would
have been so easy just to cut to a clip
earlier of Neil senior but instead they
blend both his memory and where he is
into one single image that means they
literally had to bring a cab door
dressed John Candy up again and
recreated outside scene in an indoor
scene that's a lot of work for only a
half second of screen time his
progression of thought to his conclusion
about Dell it's also very natural most
times a character which is randomly
think of a plot device out of the blue
but here he starts off thinking about
going home than being romantic with his
wife than how he was accidentally
romantic with Dell and then the two of
them talking about what he was just
thinking about their wives and homes
which of course draws into his final
thought this is a totally logical way
the human mind would lead to this
outcome it's not till you see a film do
it so smoothly that you realize how many
film don't do it
it's very flowing and natural and adds a
lot to the experience one day I'm going
to look back in the last you think so
speaking of which you know there's
something else story-wise that this
movie does differently in most films
about opposite personalities that have
to get along the big blowup at each
other is done in the last third allowing
the comedy and lack of patience to build
which usually leads to where they make
up in the last act however here the
blow-up happens in the first third which
is almost never done instead of
following the same formula of other
comedies making it easy to predict this
gets that part out of the way early so
now you don't know exactly where the
relationship is going to go because of
this it allows much more freedom for
them to give a fresher take on their
relationship this makes the times when
they do split up and get back together
all the more memorable and all the more
emotional even when Neil things Dell
stole his wallet this misunderstanding
will have gone at least 20 minutes in
your typical comedy but here they wrap
it up in just a few seconds we were
robbed do you think so this is how great
writers work with convention but also
change it around to make it something
fresh and new and one of the many
reasons this film is so wonderful hooked
up with the scribe what the hell's in
this hotel mattress to make these kind
of sounds
it's almost as uncomfortable as the
scratching sound made shortly after and
you don't want to know what's causing
either of those you may notice Dell has
a black eye near the end of their
journey this could be due to a deleted
scene but maybe it's tied in to this
line drivers a little freaky about
people riding up in his cab was Dells so
determined to get Neil home that he
actually took a hit from a paranoid
attacker just to reassure them alive
nothing can say for sure but it's
totally a possibility is this a
coincidence or what and the number one
thing you never notice about planes
trains and automobiles is there's two
handprints stained on the wall above
their hotel bed that doesn't sound like
much but really think about it what
position would require someone to put
stained hands just above their hotel
room bed yeah pretty subtle and pretty
sneaky but once you notice it you can't
stop looking at it it just adds to the
uncomfortableness of the situation as
well as the hilarity of the setup little
touches like this that you need to look
for are definitely the reason why so
many people watch this movie every
Thanksgiving see that Bears game last
week Oh a game hello game first got a
great team this year Oh
yeah that we missed I'll do any little
touches we're talking about well leave
them in the comments below and keep
talking about film that's definitely
worth talking about I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
you